>>Marc Benioff: It is my
greatest pleasure to be able
to bring this program to you today,
and I hope that the experience
that you have with George Lucas and
Bob Thurman in conversation will be
as transformation for
you in your lives
and in your organizations
as it has been for me.
These are truly two of the great
people we have in the world.
So please welcome George
Lucas and Robert Thurman.
>>Audience: [applause]
>>George: I didn't
enjoy school very much.
Occasionally I would come up with
a teacher who would inspire me,
but as I got older and I began
to work with computer technology
and telling stories
through film I began
to wonder why couldn't we
use these new technologies
to help improve the
educational process?
>>Narrator: Since 1991 the George
Lucas Educational Foundation has
chronicled what works
in public education.
>>Noel: Imagine education
at its best,
and imagine bringing the resources
of George Lucas to document it.
>>Narrator: We offer
our award-winning media
on several platforms including
documentary films, Edutopia magazine,
and our website edutopia.org
showcasing ideal learning
environments, providing
concrete examples
of how technology is
creating new opportunities
for teaching and learning.
>>Teacher: So you want to
put your GPSs up this way.
>>Narrator: We focus on
five key topic areas.
>>Teacher: What you need to
do is you rescale it so that-
>>Narrator: Project
learning: students engage
in rigorous real-world projects
to learn core subject matter
and achieve deeper understanding.
Cooperative learning: students
learn to collaborate, communicate,
and resolve conflicts
by working together.
>>Student: This represents
the scales of the alligator.
>>Narrator: Integrated studies:
isolated individual
subjects are presented
in an interdisciplinary fashion
that reflects modern knowledge
and how students learn best.
>>Student: Nothing can stop us.
>>Narrator: Comprehensive assessment.
>>Student: Transportation--
>>Narrator: Assessments measure
the full range of student ability
through multiple measures including
portfolios, performances, and tests.
>>Teacher: Writing, you're
making steady progress.
>>Narrator: Teachers: teachers
provide the human touch,
the most valuable element
in education
by nurturing the students'
interests and confidence.
>>Teacher: Look how smart you are.
>>Narrator: All of our media
comes together at edutopia.org,
a deep archive of constantly
updated information available free
on demand to a worldwide audience.
We offer everything from
classroom tips for teachers,
to tools for district-wide change.
And we invite users to join
in the discussion offering
their own suggestions
and insights for improving education.
>>Student: Doctor, I was just
curious how would this surgery differ
if somebody already
had a bypass surgery?
>>Doctor: Good question.
Fundamentally it's
the same operation.
>>George: The Educational Foundation
has really become dedicated
to taking all the best
ideas that are out there
that people are actually
experimenting with in the real world
and disseminating that information
to anybody who wants it or needs it.
>>Ryan: Edutopia has been a
resource that I've grasped
onto as an administrator and somebody
who truly believes in the power
of integrating technology
in the classroom.
The video clips in particular
on the website connected
to the stories offer
a powerful message.
>>Students: [speaking Japanese]
>>Marco: It shows you examples
of how it's working in places
where people thought they
wouldn't work or schools
that have challenges like mine.
They go out and discover the gold and
they share it with everybody else.
>>Teacher: Beautiful and we're
going to bring it right over here.
>>Student: Are we going
to have enough room
for the whole webpage
just from that one line?
>>George: I strongly believe
that education is the
single most important job
that the human race has.
I'm very excited that we have
been able to find a little spot
in the educational community where we
can help give people the tools they
need to go into their own community
and improve their own educational
systems in their own way.
>>Narrator: Experience
edutopia at www.edutopia.org.
>>Robert: That's great, George.
Well it's really great
of you to come,
George and to share your
passion with people.
>>George: Well it's great to be here.
>>Robert: That's good and thanks
to Mark and to the community
of the wonderful community
of Salesforce.com.
And maybe we should start
with your own story, George.
Like let us know a little like
how did you get to this passion?
You're the movie-maker, Star
Wars, the whole thing, Yoda.
Did Yoda tell you to
get into education?
>>Audience: [laughs]
>>George: [laughs] Well, when
I started out in the school K
through 12 I didn't
do very well at all.
I just didn't fit in.
I guess I was too much
of a daydreamer.
I really wasn't a big fan of math
and science and all of the curriculum
that they put inside the box
and I lived outside the box
and so I didn't really
have a good time.
It wasn't really until I
hit college that I began
to enjoy the educational process
because I had more control
over what I was learning.
>>Robert: Uh-huh.
>>George: And I am very
interested in social science.
And I was a history
major in high school
but I became an anthropology major
in junior college where I started
and suddenly it was a lot of fun
and I was doing much better at it.
And I realized that learning
is a fun thing to do.
>>Robert: Uh-huh.
>>George: Especially
if you're interested.
>>Robert: Right.
>>George: And that
was the primary thing.
So I went to film school.
I discovered film school.
I had no interest in
film before I got there.
I thought I was interested in art
and I wanted to be an illustrator,
and a friend of mine said "Well they
have a photography school at U.S.C."
but I discovered it wasn't
a photography school.
It was actually a cinema
photography school.
And it wasn't even a cinematography
school, it was a cinema school
and they teach you to make movies
and I said "This is insane.
You mean you go to university
to learn how to make movies?"
And but I went there, my first
semester I fell in love with it,
realized I was very good at
it and it became a passion.
I was very fortunate because your
passion, finding your passion
of what you want to do in life is
the single most difficult thing you
can do.
>>Robert: Right.
>>George: And if you can find
it, if you can find it early,
it's just a fantastic
advantage over everything
because then no matter what
happens, you're going to be happy.
>>Robert: Right.
>>George: And so later
on I was, you know,
we were sort of on the
leading edge of using computers
to develop special effects
and things in the movies,
and I was a storyteller
and I said "What
if I just combine these
two things and built a sort
of a learning machine,
a multi-media project?"
>>Robert: Right.
>>George: And I think this
would be a great way to learn.
It would be much more
interesting, much more engaging.
Started that which basically was
the beginning of the foundation,
and talked to a lot of educators.
We bring educators in for a day
twice a week in all different fields,
all different areas, experts
for years we did this.
And they kept saying "Look, don't
build a model of multimedia.
Don't show how mu-- what we need is
to be able to tell the story of how
to integrate technology into schools.
We go to conferences.
We only get an hour.
It takes us a whole
hour to explain it.
If you could tell the
story, you could do it in 10
or 15 minutes using
visuals and movies."
>>Robert: Uh-huh.
>>George: "And then we can spend the
rest of the time answering questions
and being very effective."
>>Robert: Uh-huh.
>>George: And what needs
to be told is the story
of what education should be.
>>Robert: Mm-hm.
>>George: It seemed like a very
modest thing and not very glamorous
but these people were
so passionate about it
that I picked it up and took it on.
It's been quite a while
now about 12 years.
>>Robert: Uh-huh.
>>George: That we've been doing this.
>>Robert: Right.
>>George: And what we do
is take the best practices-
>>Robert: Uh-huh.
>>George: Of what education
will look like using technology-
>>Robert: Mm-hm.
>>George: Using video, using
the Internet, using computers
and multimedia in the classroom
and what it does is it opens
a whole different paradigm
of the way we learn.
We've been saying for
ever since I've been born-
>>Robert: Uh-huh.
>>George: We've got
to change education.
We got to make it work.
It's got to be better.
It's not working.
What can we do?
And let's throw more money at it.
Let's do this.
But the great thing is
technology, the digital age-
>>Robert: Right.
>>George: The computer,
is going to do that.
>>Robert: Right.
>>George: It cannot stay
like you were 200 years ago.
It just isn't going to work.
>>Robert: Right.
>>George: So what I've
dedicated myself
to doing is saying okay
you got your computers.
>>Robert: Uh-huh.
>>George: But don't put
them in a little classroom
and teach people Word Perfect
two days a week as an elective.
>>Robert: Uh-huh.
>>George: Because the kids
already know that anyway.
Take the computers and use
them as a tool like a pencil
to help the educational process.
>>Robert: Uh-huh.
>>George: To help the learning
process for the students and out
of that we realized that it
facilitates age-old techniques
of learning which is cooperative
learning, interactive working.
>>Robert: Right.
>>George: It's project-based
learning is the cobbler.
>>Robert: Right.
>>George: Interactive
cooperative learning is Aristotle.
>>Robert: Right, right, right.
>>George: He never taught anything.
He never said "Well the way you do
it is you do this and this and this."
He always said "Well
how would you do it?
Here's a problem.
What do you think about that?"
>>Robert: Right.
>>George: And then he would either-
>>Robert: It's a dialogue
with people.
>>George: It was a dialogue.
It was a thing where the
students did the learning
and the teacher was
there to facilitate.
>>Robert: Right.
>>George: And to say "Well
have you thought of this?"
>>Robert: Right.
>>George: Lots of great theory
but there's a big hole right here.
>>Robert: Right.
>>George: Think about that.
>>George: That is the
way education should be.
>>Robert: Right.
>>George: And it's worked for
thousands and thousands of years
and that's the way
young children learn.
They learn out of curiosity.
Kids only have one job in their life,
and that is to grow
up and be an adult.
>>Robert: Right.
>>George: That's all they want.
And so you give them any kind
of adult work, they'll do it
and they'll be very excited about it.
>>Robert: Right.
>>George: So instead of saying "Learn
math", you say "Here I want you
to build an airplane but it
has to be a real airplane.
We're going to simulate
it here on the computer."
>>Robert: Uh-huh.
>>George: "But you have
to learn all the science.
You have to learn all the math, you
have to learn all the stuff in order
to get to build this airplane."
>>Robert: Right, right.
>>George: So they learn it
because they need it as a tool
and they know why they're
learning it.
That suddenly engages them in a way
and they are learning
to do something.
>>Robert: Mm-hm.
>>George: Because our
philosophy is you teach kids how
to find information.
You teach them how to assess that
information and see how true it is,
and then you use it
in a creative endeavor
to build something, to do something.
>>Robert: Right, like I was just
thinking like in geography class,
right, Google Earth get that
available to kids on their hands.
You know teachers giving a lecture
and they can zoom in on Saskatchewan.
You mentioned earlier-
>>George: Right.
>>Robert: Sometime to find
out where Saskatchewan was
when you were little.
>>George: Well we've- what we've done
is say we have narrowed our programs
into just informing people.
>>Robert: Yes.
>>George: We gather the information.
We say "Google Earth,
look on edutopia.
You'll see one of the
tools you have available
to you is Google Earth
if you do geography."
>>Robert: Right.
>>George: But it shows you all the
things that are available to you.
>>Robert: Mm-hm.
>>George: But it also shows-
>>Robert: You have that on the
website, teachers can use that.
>>George: Yeah, and it shows you
then how to organize a classroom-
>>Robert: Uh-huh.
>>George: Around these ideas using
the technology: cameras, computers,
the Internet, to enhance
the learning experience.
>>Robert: Mm-hm.
>>George: And you can do it,
there's a zillion different ways.
We show the ones that are
actually being used now.
>>Robert: Right.
>>George: All this is very,
very, new and all we're trying
to do is make it more available,
the information more available.
>>Robert: Right.